IT’S NOW BECOME, WELL, A TV SHOW
FAVORITE.
BUT FIRST, WE TURN ONCE AGAIN
TONIGHT TO THE CRISIS THAT IS ON
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
EVEN THOUGH THE DHS SECRETARY
AND JOE BIDEN DENY IT.
IT’S GETTING REALLY, REALLY BAD.
WE HAVE TENT CITIES.
WE HAVE COVID OUTBREAKS.
WE HAVE OWE FLOWING DETENTION
CENTERS.
WE HAVE DANGEROUS CARTELS
GETTING MORE POWERFUL NOW BY THE
DAY, BUT THE BINDEN
ADMINISTRATION WANTS YOU TO
BELIEVE THERE IS NO CRISIS
WHATSOEVER.
HOWEVER BREAKING, SOMEONE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOW ORDERED A
TEAM OF SENIOR OFFICIALS TO THE
BORDER TO WITNESS THE CRISIS IN
PERSON, AND AS WE REPORTED ALL
WEEK, EMERGENCY MIGRANT SHELTERS
AT THE BORDER ARE ALREADY
OPERATING AT NEAR FULL CAPACITY
AS OF TUESDAY, AND THIS INCLUDES
BIDEN’S TENTS, BIDEN’S TARPS,
THEN, OF COURSE, THE TINY CARGO
SHIPPING CONTAINERS THAT THEY
HAVE, BARS ON THE TINY WINDOWS,
THAT’S FOR KIDS BUT DON’T WORRY,
THEY WON’T LET YOU INSIDE TO SEE
IT BUT THEY PROMISE US THEY PUT
BUTTERFLIES ON THE WINDOWS.
ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT, THE
CDC IS NOW ALLOWING CHILD
MIGRANT SHELTERS TO EXPAND
BEYOND 100% CAPACITY, ABANDONING
THE REQUIREMENT TO STAY NEAR 50%
BECAUSE OF COVID.
NOW THIS HAS TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF MIGRANTS, THAT ARE EXPECTED
AT THE BORDER NOW JUST WEEKS
AWAY.
THE DHS ITSELF BELIEVES A RECORD
117,000 UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
WILL BE COMING HERE ALONE AND
WILL BE INTERCEPTED.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
EYEING A SITE IN THE
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA JUST
SOUTH OF RICHMOND AT FORT LEE AS
A BRAND-NEW SHELTER FOR THESE
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS, AS A PART
OF THEIR PLAN TO SPREAD OUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ALL ACROSS
THE CONTINENTAL U.S.
AND MEANWHILE, JUST SOUTH OF
CALIFORNIA, A TENT CITY FILLED
WITH MIGRANTS HAS NOW GROWN TO
OVER 1,000 PEOPLE.
MANY OF THEM ARE WEARING BIDEN
CAMPAIGN GEAR, HOLDING UP SIGNS,
PLEASE, BIDEN, JOE, LET US IN.
IN LESS THAN 50 DAYS IN OFFICE,
THE BOARDER PATROL HAS TOTALLY
BEEN SUBORDINATED TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND DETERIORATED
UNDER BIDEN’S POLICIES BUT IS
ANYBODY SURPRISED?
BIDEN PROMISED TO HAND OUT
AMNESTY TOO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
HE’S DOING SO.
HE VOWED TO INCREASE ASYLUM
VISAS.
HE VOWED TO STOP AND END ALL
BORDER WALL CONSTRUCTION.
HE’S DONE THAT.
PEOPLE GOT THEIR PINK SLIPS.
HE’S ORDERED BORDER PATROL TO
.OES EVERYTHING BY EXECUTIVE
FIAT.
AND HERE’S WHITE HOUSE
SPOKESPERSON PSAKI SAYING THESE
POLICIES ARE HERE TO SAY.
>> HAVE THERE BEEN ANY POLICIES
ABOUT REVERSING THE POLICY OF
ALLOWING ALL ILLEGAL CHILDREN
INTO THE UNITED STATES?
>> NO, NONE AT ALL.
>> SEAN: AS THIS BECOMES A
BIGGER DISASTER THEY MAY WANT TO
CIRCLE BACK.
OPEN BORDERS, CATCH AND RELEASE,
AMNESTY, ALL IN THE BIDEN
SANCTUARY STATES OF AMERICA, ALL
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC, AND
YET THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
BYPASSING LAWS OF THIS LAND,
ABANDONING THE BOARD PATROL AND
OPENING THE FLOOD GATES.
NOW WE HAVE DANGEROUS CARTELS
GETTING RICH THROUGH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
WE SAW THAT LAST WEEKEND IN
CALIFORNIA.
DRUGS LIKE, OH, YOU KNOW, 90% OF
THE HEROIN IN THIS COUNTRY,
FENTANYL, POURING ACROSS THE
BORDER, NOT HELPING OUR OPIOID
CRISIS AND NOW A MASSIVE
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS IS LOOMING
FOR ALL OF US BUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WON’T EVEN ADMIT
THERE IS A PROBLEM.
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT IT IN A
NEW STATEMENT, "THE SPIRALING
TSUNAMI AT THE BORDER IS
OVERWHELMING LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
IT IS DEPLETING BUDGETS,
CROWDING HOSPITALS, AND TAKING
JOBS FROM LEGAL AMERICAN
WORKERS."
WHEN I LEFT OFFICE, WE HAD
ACHIEVED THE MOST SECURE BORDER
IN OUR COUNTRY’S HISTORY.
UNDER BIDEN, IT WILL SOON BE
WORSE.
MUCH WORSE, MORE OUT OF CONTROL
THAN EVER BEFORE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RIGHT AND
THIS WEEK OUR OWN SARAH CARTER,
SHE’S BEEN DOCUMENTING ALL OF
THIS FIRST HAND.
LAST NIGHT AFTER OUR SHOW, SHE
WENT OUT AND OBTAINED THIS
EXCLUSIVE FOOTAGE OF AT LEAST
ONE GROUP OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
YES, ATTEMPTING TO ENTER THIS
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, NOT ABIDING